I put that in defending lefties. I'm putting that in anywhere.
>> so would you say Hutch is Hutch defending lefties? >> Is
Hutch defending lefties? Was Hutch defending lefties then? Was
Hutch defending lefties? >> Already running. Already running.
>> Cuz you're a part of a cult and people are lying about
my views.
>> You are a part of a cult and that cult is lying about
my views. Let's
>> Now, without further ado, let's do cuz I got to do this
first Pisgo call and it's over this whole thing from yesterday.
So, Pisgo, we watched the Pisgo being on the panel with Taylor
Lorenz and Hutch. Pisgo getting condescended to by Hutch repeatedly,
right? But just for the sake of, you know, refreshing your mind,
when Pisgo would go to interrupt, this is the kind of thing he
was met with, right? >> But if you're going to take issue
with like random sort of characterizations, and again, I understand
>> think it's random. I don't think it was deliberate.
I think it was deliberate, >> I guess >> Once you
get to there, I mean, like I mean, why don't you why don't you
go there and just ask Taylor? >> with the copy editor.
>> to have a conversation with her. I don't know why you're
jumping in here. >> Hey, no, no, no, no, because it's kind
>> So, Hutch, by the way, major gaslighting when he goes
to Pisgo's stream and tries to tell Pisgo, "Actually, what's
going on here is you were being really rude to me. You were actually
being a to me, Pisgo, the whole time. You were You were being
really mean. You were doing yes or Oh, wait. No, it was Hutch
who was being extremely condescending in the first place. Cool.
And that's not even That's not even the only interruption where
he's a
What about this one? >> This article is >> he's quite
as bad in this one. >> actually wrong, then I highly encourage
them to ask for a correction, but no one has asked for a >> by
steps? >> Saying that it's but they are not centrist. No
one >> Let's just do it step by step. Hutch, is it your
contention that it's inaccurate to call Olivia Juliana a centrist?
>> I do believe that, yes, and I think that >> of
what?
>> intentionally. Well, I don't know why you're playing
the >> You understand that Taylor used the word. It's a
pejorative. I don't know why you're playing dumb here.
So separate that intent. So you can make a you can make a critique
of an article. >> This is just signaling Pisco's being
difficult again with me. Pisco's acting like he doesn't understand
what I'm saying. Pisco's being difficult. Why is he sweeping?
This is all subtext to what Hutch is saying here. Why is Pisco
sweeping for Taylor Lorenz right now? Right? That's what he keeps
doing over and over again. Then we have Pisco versus Hutch. We
also covered this on stream. We've got one clip from that. >> I
would say centrism like centrist would like more or less synonymous
with moderate. It could mean someone that has a decently balanced
policy preference
>> Any differences between centrist and moderate would
be quibbling. Is basically what Hutch concedes here,
Now, Pisco kept getting gaslit by people. A whole bunch of people
are acting like he's out of his mind, right? He goes he posts
this, The Centrist Files, and he basically goes to say everybody's
telling me that you can't that like there's some massive difference
between centrist and moderate, right?
And he disagrees, and he goes look at all the people who use
these things more or less interchangeably.
And he does this whole thread. Now, if you want a clue of how
annoying some of these people are who disagree with him. Got
169 comments, 144 likes. So he is just getting like hardcore
brigaded, right? This is going way outside of his reach. So he
basically gives a bunch of reasons for his for his arguments,
and I believe the usurp one is the top one. So this usurp the
chef guy who's like a big time Destiny cultist guy, okay?
He comes and he says, "Pisco, I love you, bud, but this thread
can't be serious. This is the same guy who tried to get Pisco
and Destiny to talk before.
Same guy, massive Destiny fan. He's the guy who did this video.
>> Hey, son. How you doing? I'm happy I was finally able
to wake you out of your slump. Cuz for a while >> The performative
eating, the performative like guys are making a 50-second video,
so I need to like pop something into my mouth and eat to show
that I'm very nonchalant. I'm actually so nonchalant and not
bothered by making this video like I'm so nonchalant and not
bothered that I can pop some stuff into my mouth and eat right
now. Check it out, man. Check Check it out. Eating in a pre-recorded
video would already be bad, Private Huffer. It would already
be bad, but it is a 50-second video.
It's literally a 50-second video.
>> Hey, son. How you doing? I'm happy I was finally able
to wake you out of your slump. Cuz for a while
you had your pants on and you were just too afraid to have any
conversations with people that disagree with you. But I know
>> Oh, wow. Wow. People had their pants on. That's crazy.
Okay. So, what does he say to Pisco? He says to Pisco, "Pisco,
I love you, bud, but this threat can't be serious. I know you
enjoy a good bit every now and again, but I mean, come on. Is
this really a position you think is worthy of defending? Cuz
I don't think you even believe that." And it's like
"Why would you come in and say something along the lines of Pisco,
I just don't Pisco, why would you even argue this? Pisco, why
would you even argue this,
So, basically, this is already starting on like the weird like,
"I don't even think you really believe that. Pisco, are you really
trying to argue right now on something you're clearly correct
on that everybody's acting like you're not correct on? Maybe
Pisco, have you thought about how like this doesn't matter at
all? That like why don't you just accept that you're like rude
to Hutch? That This is, by the way, this the idea that this is
not true is being used as evidence that Pisco was being like
totally unreasonable when he was trying to help Hutch. Like Pisco's
being totally unreasonable in trying to help Hutch at all.
Right? That's This argument is central to that. So, what Pisco
is basically proving is that he wasn't being unreasonable and
he was trying to help
And they're all going, "Pisco, there's no reason for you to try
to prove that you weren't being like a disgusting piece of [__]
to your co-host."
Well, yeah, there is cuz some people are trying to say that Pisco
is being a piece of [__] to his co-host. So, obviously
he's going to argue against that, right? And this this claim
that centrist and moderate are are not even close to the same
is central to it. Because then Pisco is totally unreasonable
for ever interrupting
It all flows from that. So, when we get this, it's like, why
are you even arguing this, man? Let's see what Pisco says in
response.
Yes, I'm defending everything I'm saying because everything I've
said is true. Please identify a false statement I
Yes. So, he's He's basically saying, well, I'm correct. And they're
all going They all go, Pisco, it doesn't It actually doesn't
matter if you're correct cuz like you're kind of being weird,
man. Yes, I'm defending everything I'm saying because everything
I've said is true. Please identify a false statement I made.
I'm at work, so I can't go digging, but I feel like you're missing
the forest for the trees. I'm just really not online at all,
man. I'm like not online at all, so it's it's probably difficult
for me to actually make this argument. Uh-huh. Okay.
So, I'm at work, but I think feel like you're missing the forest
for the trees. None of this is about a single false statement,
but more a refusal to admit a misunderstanding. Moderate equals
in the middle of the party you identify with. Centrist is in
the middle of the two parties. You could say moderate Democrat,
centrist Democrat. These would be You might even I could understand
So, centrist Democrat, I would say centrist Democrat is
at least reasonably could be two things, so it doesn't really
help you, right?
Like centrist Democrat to me might mean a Democrat who's closer
to the center or a Democrat who lines up very tightly with the
middle of the line positions in the party, right?
It could be either one.
Anyway, we keep going. I can't imagine that you would have disagreed
with that statement prior to the most recent episode of Livin'
Learn, and I would find it hard so hard to believe if you said
otherwise. But maybe you would have So, I don't know, but that's
why I felt like you were doing another one of your bits. What
does it Hold on. Do you understand Like what Pisco is doing the
whole time is he's going, oh, I think this is like a bit ambiguous.
I'm trying to I think he uses the term linear a lot. Linearize?
I'm trying to like cut this down. You know what I'm saying? I'm
trying to cut this down so that instead of
instead of
leaving the ambiguity there, I'm trying to resolve it so that
we can move forward with no concerns. You know what I'm saying?
That's like to me, that's pretty obviously what's going on there.
And there's nothing wrong with doing that.
So, like Pisco's just offering. And for anybody to get upset
with him or say it's not relevant, well, if he thinks there's
ambiguity there and that you could be wrong or you're setting
yourself up to lose an argument,
right? Which is what Pisco was arguing, then yeah, obviously
he should raise it. Anyway, yeah, I don't know where you're getting
those definitions from. And surely there they are not the only
plausible only plausible meanings of the terms. Multiple prominent
Democrats use the terms interchangeably. I proved that. The dictionaries
label them as synonyms. I showed that. Seems I'm right. He's
literally like, I'm making an argument. Could you contend with
the argument instead of just being like, I feel like you were
not really doing a thing that was smart, Pisco? Like Pisco, I
feel like you were sort of like just with Hutch.
Oh, what? I got those definitions based on the way people have
used the term. I'm This is all
This is all basically people who are in a cult trying to use
the reasonable person standard.
Right? Like total cultist, total total cultist being like, well,
a reasonable person who I'm around all the time would think this
means that. It's like, uh-huh. Now, argue that that's the way
it's used or [__] off. I don't care about any argument.
All you have to do is show other people using it. That's all
you got to do. Show Show other people like taking contention
with these two being used synonymously. That's all you got to
do. I know you used a definition and like a bunch of evidence
of people who are political influencers in some way, but like
I feel like you're wrong and so have you considered how maybe
you're crazy and crashing out? Have you Have you thought about
that?
Imagine if instead of online an online argument, this was happening
in court. If that were the case, would you be willing to go in
front of a judge with your job and credibility on the line and
sincerely produce this as your evidence? Of course not. Oh, it's
like the dumbest statement I've seen today. Would you be willing
to go and advocate on behalf of your client and make the best
argument possible for them? Uh yeah, that's literally what it
is to be a lawyer. That's actually I think in their oaths. I
think they swear an oath to do the best they can to defend their
client. That's quite literally what being a lawyer is. Holy [__]
But this is This is the cult brain, right? This is the cultist
brain. They think these are normal statements. They think they're
saying things that are not
Oh, you can't just claim victory after your own reply. That's
not how this
I mean, how people how people in court prove meaning of words
is through dictionaries and usage. People will cite will like
cite Madison, look at a legal dictionary. It's standard to look
at that kind of stuff. Here I'm citing prominent Dems and dictionaries.
I don't know what else you would use.
How else would you prove this argument? Pisco, would you really
cite a dictionary in court?
Yes. Yes, I would.
>> It's and it's like such base level
At some point I feel like they're just going to start arguing
like, Pisco, do you really think that like humans breathe oxygen
and exhale carbon dioxide? Do you Would you really argue that?
Pisco, would you Yes. Yes, I would argue facts. I would argue
true facts about the world. Of course, I would. Of course, I
would.
People in DGG, don't you remember when DGGers used to like arguments?
When people would argue something based on their beliefs? That's
wild now. Apparently, that's like totally anathema to anything
Destiny's community wants. Which by the way is what this is.
Is Destiny's community targeting Pisco once again. Yeah, this
was the one. You guys remember this? It's not surprising he's
targeting Pisco's community. Big conversation about doxxing going
on with Destiny, Mouton, and the Zip Zip guy. I don't know who
this is. Check it out. Let's see what they have to say.
>> Uh, wait, so Destiny you say like it's like justified
like doxxing the guy? >> Yeah, that whole server should
be wiped off the internet. Every couch should be perma-banned
from Discord and everybody in there should be probably locked
in a stainless atom for like 12 months cuz they basically been
long like long-term stalking and harassing me and people around
me for yeah, about a year now. It's been I think it's pretty
relentless. It's pretty insane. And when it's gotten to the point
to where that say the guy is literally bragging about emailing
like a victim in my court case and is and everybody in that server
is like clapping along and laughing at it is yeah, I think it
>> Oh, yeah, the total mischaracterization of that as well.
He'll like say he'll state a claim and then he'll show like a
screenshot and the screenshot won't correspond to the claim once
whatsoever.
And nobody questions it. Very bizarre. >> I'm good on that,
Chief. >> Sorry, we got to keep going for just a little
bit. >> dox like any other like DGGers though. >> They
don't need to. Every doxx is posted on Kiwi Farms so they actively
collaborate with then why would they doxx anybody in Destiny's
Discord server? That'd be
>> You think um you kind of overreacted of like by like
doxxing a couple of people inside the J Soc community a little
bit?
You think you overreacted by doxxing people in the J Soc community?
No. No, I don't think so.
>> No. They I don't think they have like like I'm not I'm
not trying to like downplay their like I don't think they caused
you like physical harm, right? I don't think I'm not sure if
I'm allowed
I don't think I caused them physical harm, did I? >> Not
that I know of. Not that I >> No. I'm wondering I mean
like other examples of like doxxing like you or >> I just
I don't I just I don't care what happens to any of these communities
like Peace Go's included. I think that all you guys are weird
and need to be away from the internet. I think it's all like
gotten way out of hand. I'm like I just >> Wow. Peace Go's
too, eh? Peace Go's community needs to be wiped from the That's
what we were waiting for is conversation about doxxing and he's
going to with a bunch of his community watching start talking
about how Peace Go's community needs to be wiped from the internet.
I don't care what happens to any of these people. These people
all need to >> Hey spider, are you not going to wait comfortable
talking [__] and being weird and talking to harassing
people? It's kind of weird. It probably gives Jsoc and his community
more ammo now. But really, I thought a few people left the server
once people started getting doxed. That's what I saw. >> That's
like that's like the goal, I guess. Why am I doxing people? Cuz
I want people to leave that guy's community. Okay, you Why are
you admitting to totally insane things?
Why are you being totally insane?
Uh very funny. So, with all that being said, that's that's We're
watching basically
Destiny continue on this campaign. He really wants um He really
wants to [__] with Pisco.
I kind of feel like it's weird to me when I watch Pisco and Destiny's
friends, like their mutual friends, really not care about this
campaign that's being undertaken. It's just odd to me, personally.
Like But maybe they're unaware. Maybe they're just all totally
unaware. They have no idea what's going on. They They don't follow.
They're not sure. Possibly. I don't think so, but maybe.
So anyway, this I I just want to show you there's like a there's
a group of there's like this cult that want to [__]
with Pisco. They want to [__] with Pisco because
Destiny has sicked them on Pisco repeatedly. And so now we'll
watch one of the cultists, this guy Usurp the Chef, come in and
try to talk to Pisco and try to formulate an argument. And it's
going to be very strange. It's just going to be very weird, all
right? All righty. So,
what's good, my brother? What's going >> Uh not [clears throat]
too much. Triggered watching some ice hockey right now, but that's
normal. Um
yeah, not much. I was just wondering to know what was going on
kind of with with you cuz Mhm. Seems like I don't know, there
seemed to be a whole little controversy about a word. I guess
like from my perspective, it it it seems like I just wanted to
like I understand that like on Livin Learn there's the the four
of you guys and you guys don't always want to, you know, just
like each other off and agree with each other all the time. But,
it does seem like you and Hutch like to get into it a lot. And
I just
from my perspective, it it it does seem that you, for some reason,
attack bog standard liberals more
in defense of far left people. >> Yeah, no. It's like that's
just wrong. >> I know, I completely I don't think you're
a secret tankie in hiding. I do I do think you are a vote blue
no matter who liberal. But, just going through the Lib and Learn
like um catalog, just like try I was just trying to refresh of
what happened, you know, a couple months back. And like I just
got a couple
every fight seemed to be you and Hutch about a third party. And
that third
you and Hutch about a third party. Dude, the funny thing is is
it's like you and Hutch, you and Hutch, you and Hutch. Yeah,
Hutch gets in a lot of fights with Because he's a [__]
He literally is low IQ. He's basically incapable of understanding
what he's trying to argue a lot of the time. That's why where's
Pesco fighting with one of these intelligent people outside of
Lib and Learn or on a stream? Like where's he fighting with somebody
else? Cuz I've watched Hutch be screamed at by Josiah. I've never
seen Josiah actually angry. I I don't believe I've ever seen
Josiah raise his voice outside of his conversation with Hutch.
So, realistically, there is there is like a problem here. And
there is somebody who's in the wrong. Somehow
in all of this, it's getting put on Pesco. I don't get it. I
literally I don't understand. It keeps getting pushed onto Pesco.
Pesco, you're the one who's wrong. Well, sorry. When I say I
don't get it, I know exactly what it is. It's like I said, it's
the person who wanted his community destroyed. It's the person
who has a vendetta against him. It's that community who has a
vendetta against him. That is what it >> party was always
a lefty.
And it seemed that the conversation was always you not necessarily
defending the lefty. It could also be you playing devil's advocate
for that person. But every single time that pair Can I give you
a couple of examples? Can I give you a couple of examples?
Um there you had um the argument with Hutch on >> I wish
Pesco had said, "Okay, you you can give me examples, but basically
you're going to have to have an ought for how I should have behaved
differently given the context of the situation. So, I'm going
to explain to you why I did what I did, and then you're going
to have to explain to me why that was wrong and how I could have
been better. That's what you have to do. Cuz I don't think this
guy understands that you can't just say, "I felt really weird.
It made me feel bad in my tummy when you were mean to Hutch."
>> on the whole who would you rather vote for Hassan versus
um J.D. Vance. >> Right, so that is your favorite paradigm,
right? That's not me defending a lefty. Is it? Do you find that
that's defending a lefty? >> It well, it was cuz you were
defending I put that in the defending lefties. I'm putting that
>> Okay, so would you say Hutch Would you say Hutch is
defending a lefty? >> He was defending and voting for anybody
but a Republican. >> no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no. >> You actually yelled, "Pesco, now
stop aping me." >> Well, it was cuz you were defending
I put that in the defending lefties. >> a lefty? Okay,
so would you say Hutch Was Hutch defending a lefty? Was Hutch
defending [laughter] a lefty? Was Hutch defending a lefty then?
Was Hutch defending Epstein? Would you say Hutch is defending
Epstein? >> He was defending and voting for anybody but
a Republican. >> Was he Was he defending Epstein
>> No, because he wasn't >> Okay, so I wasn't defending
lefties, >> stop. You don't even let me >> Stop,
stop. Wait, just stop. Stop arguing. I I like it better when
you don't say anything. >> Explain why. This is the problem.
>> All right? You I put that in the category because you
were saying you were essentially in a roundabout way defending
Hassan in that situation. >> Would you Would you rather
have Hitler or Mussolini as as your president? >> So the
second example was your argument >> Wait, already running.
Already running. Wait, can we can we just stay on the one first?
Can we just do one by one? >> is what happens a lot of
times in your
dude, this is now this is where I'm going to start freaking the
[__] out,
>> No, we can't stay on one thing where I'm wrong. This
is what happens in your conversations, Pisco. You get really
caught up on whether or not the person's like actually arguing
something that's correct, and you just won't let them move on
without them getting like without them acknowledging that they
were wrong. Right? This guy knows he was He obviously sees why
he's wrong, and he wants to move on.
Right? He wants to move on immediately because he can see that
he's wrong now, and Pisco, can't you see that like it's really
weird when you like think I should acknowledge that I totally
made up my first point. No, it's not. No, it's not weird. That's
exactly what you should do. >> All right, then there was
the Hutch argument for the Democratic actions during the government
shutdown. So you had a big argument with Hutch. Now this was
more
>> Mhm. Again, attack you were attacking the liberal. Then
we had the Hutch argument on whether AOC's or others should have
endorsed Mondani.
okay, sorry. You don't you don't want me to you don't want me
to interject, right? You don't want me to actually contest any
of these. >> Uh [snorts] actually go go for it. >> all
wrong. So let me start with the first one. So obviously and doing
the lesser of two evils argument, it's not entailed that I'm
like defending lefties any more than it's entailed that Hutch
is defending Epstein or if it were a white nationalist versus
a MAGA person and he says a white nationalist, do you think it's
fair to say that Hutch was defending white nationalism?
>> Okay, so then in what sense is it fair to say I'm defending
lefties when I give that answer oh I would prefer Hassan over
like uh Fetterman.
>> You were the reason people were thinking
>> Do you hear the SSRI side?
>> You were the reason people were thinking that was because
when you when Hutch gave the example, yeah, I know. So, when
you gave the example of Epstein versus Who was it? Trump or or
Vance? Epstein versus Vance.
What The reason that he said he would vote for Epstein Why did
Hutch say he would vote for Epstein?
>> Why are you asking me a question? I asked you a question.
>> Because I know Okay, fine. Now it's the same thing.
Because Hutch asked that because he knew or he did not know Epstein's
political views. So, he viewed Epstein as just a box standard
liberal. That's what he said he would vote for Epstein. Just
that. Nope, repeat it. >> Okay, so please listen to me
when I'm asking something, okay? I'm I'll be honest, I forgot
too. This guy's triggering me, so I forgot what Peace Go asked.
I try to listen to you when you're talking. I'm asking you please
listen to me when I'm talking. So, I'm I I asked you a question
and I said, "If it's the case that Hutch's defense and Hutch's
the lesser of two evils Oh, why am I why am I doing like a defense
when you don't think when Hutch does the lesser of two evils,
it's not a defense. But when I do a defense or sorry, when I
say the lesser of two evils or I try to make an argument to help,
you're suddenly defending the other person. I Hey, there's a
better way to approach
Why is that defense of the thing that like you're attacking?
>> argument on his account as between horrible people including
but not limited to Epstein, including white nationalists, whatever,
and just resolving that issue. If that's not considered sweeping
for the respective group that he's, you know, choosing and uh
you know,
holding his nose to vote for. If that's the case that that's
not sweeping in that context, why would it be sweeping or defending
in my context when I answer
>> So, I would
Mhm, I would discr- or disertain like the boat two different
versions where I would agree with you if Hutch, you know, voted
for the said he would vote for the white nationalist. And if
for the problem like if for 8 to 12 months before that, Hutch
has been kind of dancing with and kind of people have been confused
about whether or not he really supports white nationalists or
not even though he says he doesn't. I think it would be a little
different, yeah. I think that would make it more aligned with
your situation because before that conversation, the Hassan and
Vaush one, there have been other couple little arguments like
this where people had come to you and said, "Hey, it seems like
you're attacking liberals more than >> Okay, so it's not
the case that there's parody there. You're you're kind of baking
into all of this a preconceived notion or assumption. >> say
it's parody. So, yeah, let me go back. So, I don't think it's
parody today because Hutch doesn't have the history of defending
white nationalists
>> That's what you're trying to prove.
Do you understand that people That's the conclusion, right? The
conclusion
>> Wait, what?
I think you sweep for tankies. Okay, can you prove that?
Well, here's an example. Okay, well, you say with that example
that Hutch Hutch isn't defending white nationalists or Epstein
when he like does the lesser of two evils, right?
But now, you're saying I sweep for lefties. And he's like, "Well,
it's cuz you have a track record of sweeping for
What were you just trying to prove? What did How did this conversation
start?
This conversation started we stopped in your first example. Your
very first I'm going to prove that you sweep for tankies, Pisco,
by
referencing your history of sweeping for
So cool. So cool. That's definitely not a mistake at all. That's
definitely not [__] up. That's definitely not wrong.
That's definitely not a totally broken way of thinking about
things at all, man. You're doing great. >> So, I'm just
going to explain something. The conclusion you're trying to prove
right now is that this is part of a track record. And so, this
is the thing called begging the question. You can't assume the
conclusion as a premise of your argument, as the component of
it to prove the case, right? You started this by trying to prove
the case that I have this track record of defending
lefties. Now, you're baking it into one of the premises of your
argument to try to construe my answer of that hypothetical differently
than you would construe my answer to the hypothetical on Epstein.
Do you understand the circularity problem there? >> But
do you understand that I haven't gone through all my examples
because you wanted to stop?
No, it's not a problem of of the examples. Like if whatever's
feeding into the examples, if part of what's feeding into the
examples and your construal of them is a conclusion you're trying
to demonstrate, it's called begging the question. >> No,
it's not I'm not trying I'm not begging the question. I'm using
the examples I have to make my point.
Am I trying to prove >> What is the claim you're trying
to >> I'm trying to What am I trying to prove? What am
I doing? It's Dr. Carlson. I don't even know what I'm trying
to prove. I don't even
I don't even know what I'm trying to prove. I could be trying
to prove
wonder why everybody on the internet thinks one way about you
and you >> Ah, this is where the real gaslighting
Hey Pisco, haven't you wondered why everybody on the internet
thinks one way about you? Have you ever wondered about that?
It's like, bro, Pisco, this gaslighting can't work. It cannot
work, right? Like Pisco gets referenced by Kyle Kulinski, by
Crystal Ball, by a bunch of huge
leftist influencers as like an authority on the law.
He doesn't need your
He doesn't need your backing to believe in himself.
He doesn't need it. So, this gaslighting doesn't work. And this
is man, I feel
I feel like I understand how some other people have felt, especially
like Max. It's like I think I think some people in that DGG sphere
have gotten to the point where they like there's this thing where
they'll embrace someone, like Food Shops for example, who has
no talent, can't make an argument, has nothing like good about
their content, right? There's just nothing there. They're not
good at making arguments, they're not good at analyzing anything.
They He of just sperg out sniff markers,
and be weird. And they'll ri- they'll raise that person up, right?
They'll give them viewership, and then they'll go, "Hey, everybody
in the internet thinks this about you." And to that person who
doesn't have anybody else who watches or cares about anything
they do, that's true.
That's true that they have no that the entire internet that is
concerned with thinks they're like doing something wrong in that
case, right? Like their entirely based their their whole world
is based on those viewers. And they're so used to that a lot
of these DG people that they think they can just argue this way.
Pisco's got validation outside of the cult. He doesn't need validation
within the from the cult cuz he's out of
And so this argument that everybody on the internet actually
just thinks you're weird, Pisco. Who cares?
Why does Pisco have a [__] background? I don't know
why he's got the weird background right now. I assume he didn't
want to turn his cam on. So he's like not got some of his overlays
on. That's all I could think. But it's it's just funny that it's
like, "Dude, everybody Have you ever thought about why everybody
in the internet thinks you're like weird? They all have the same
opinion of you, Pisco?"
Dude. Holy.
>> you trying to prove? >> What is the claim you're
trying to >> I'm trying to wonder why everybody on the
internet thinks one way about you, and you are the only person
who really can't see what everyone else is seeing right now.
>> Isn't it This just to be clear, this is again why I
why I go, "Dude, this is why I go and react to this stuff." Cuz
I do think it's important that somebody can react to it. And
technically I watched a decent amount of this already, so this
isn't like a reaction. But usually I'm just reacting to Pisco.
I just have to go and say like, "I understand you. I know what
you're trying to say. You're I'm not going to let them gaslight
you, okay? I'm not going to let them gaslight you. Everyone in
the internet thinks this about you." Sorry, we'll go one more
time. I won't pause it this time. >> on the internet thinks
one way about you, and you are the only person who really can't
see what everyone else is seeing right now. >> Isn't it
obvious? >> Go on. >> Cuz you're a part of a cult
and people are lying about my views.
LET'S GO!
LET'S [__] GO!
ALL my
god.
You are a part of a cult and that cult is lying about my views.
This guy's a part of the Pisco snark cult. Let's
>> What cult am I part of? >> You're a part of a
cult that considers
uh take that is seen on the side of Hasan [__]
um indicative of bad faith commie sweeping. And so on that worldview,
of
It's so awesome.
No, he doesn't want to say the cult directly. You can't name
the cult directly. You give them power if you name them directly,
okay? Bro,
it's so crazy.
Oh my god, it's so crazy.
And you know, you know the people in that cult have just like
declared a fatwa on Pisco. Like for him saying this, they are
going to lose their minds. Pisco's totally lost. He's like a
part of the the other group now. He's like he's so crazy. >> The
same way I'm talking to you. >> well I'm asking you to
provide one account of a take that I've had that's unjustified,
that's a bad take, and let's go. >> that fits this pattern.
In other words, you need to prove a take that isn't explained
by it being correct and accurate and that fits in >> Dude,
what are the what are the grunts, man? What are the grunts, dog?
Why are you grunting into your mic right now? What are the grunts,
bro? They're obvious, right? >> Why do you think this keeps
happening to >> explained it. >> Back to the gaslighting.
I I seem to have no argument to make.
>> Why do you think this keeps happening to you, Pisco?
Why do you think it's like you and only you? Well, Pisco, why
do you think this keeps happening to you? Pisco, why do you think
And I feel like the answer could easily be from him. Pisco go
like, wait, well, it's a it's a cult. And then the guy would
go, wait, no, but there's like a track record. Pisco go, that's
what you're trying to
And then hopefully Pisco ends the call, but let's see. >> Did
you not hear the answer? Repeat it. Okay. I said that you were
part of a >> No, no, no, no, no, no, not >> not Why
do Why does everybody else Like why does your co-host think this?
>> Well, listen. Let's not Let's not try
>> And unfortunately, this is unfortunately for Pisco,
this is the one part where the usurp guy wins. I'm sorry. I'm
sorry.
But Pisco, you unfortunately have to admit that that's what's
going on there, too. You do have to admit that cuz it's very
clear what's going on there to everybody else. >> I don't
I'm not saying I don't think he's in a cult, right? >> Yeah,
I I haven't I haven't heard Hutch say that I'm a bad faith sweeper
for >> I didn't say you're a bad When did Did those words
come out of my mouth? >> Yeah, so so now Yes, did my Does
those words come out of my mouth? Not precisely, but it's 100%
what you And if Pisco went back and watched it, right? I told
you earlier, it seems like you end up sweeping. You You work
against liberals for tankies.
That's what the guy said. Right?
That's what the guy said. And now he goes, whoa, well, sorry,
for leftists, he said, not tankies. And so Pisco's maybe maximizing
it a bit. He's hyper hyperbolizing it a little bit. But not really
that much. It's like basically the exact same connotation, no?
>> I don't know what you're claiming my my co-host thinks
about me. No, I
I came into this conversation wondering why this always continues
to happen to you because you >> I'm just going to I'm just
going to keep reinforcing. I came into this conversation why
wondering
Why does this always happen to Pisco? Why is Pisco always the
one who's like weird and argumentative and never produces a good
solution?
>> Now he's wondering well that's that's what he keeps
saying. By the way, that was that was the thing you were looking
to demonstrate is that Pisco's doing something bad. That's how
you entered the conversation. He's been saying oh I wonder why
this always happens to you. Why do you think this always happens
to you, man? >> seem to be the only body the only person
on your show that can that constantly gets into fights with his
co-host. >> What do you mean constantly? >> that
it's it seems that usually >> Oh, he changed it. Why do
you constantly get into fights with your co-host, man? Is that
weird how you constantly get into fight with your co-host? >> If
you and you actually said something at the very beginning of
this conversation
looping on semantic clarity and I think that perfectly encapsulates
the problem that happens in in in conversations that you get
in. I what I what it feel
>> So, again, looping on semantic clarity is only bad if
the semantic clarity isn't required. Pisco has has literally
laid out why he feels the semantic clarity is required and then
he gave you a counterexample of if you don't have the semantic
clarity, if you're not clear that you are really worried about
Taylor's intent more than whether or not Olivia Juliana self-identifies
as a centrist. If you're not worried about that, you're up. You're
going to lose the argument. >> Feels like for me cuz I
don't think you're a bad bad faith actor. I don't think that
you're a secret lefty wanting to sweep for Hassan. What I think
is that as simple as it is, you just get
>> Well, why I am stubborn? >> You don't want to
ever admit that you were wrong and once you get into a
it's it's it's almost impossible to dig you out of it. >> Yeah,
I know. That's that's some that Destiny has said about me. >> You've
heard him say that about me?
>> WAIT, THERE'S NO WAY IT'S THAT OBVIOUS. HOLD ON. HOLD
ON. Hold on. Hold on. Go. Go Go again. >> has said about
me. >> You've heard him say that about me?
That's some [__] that Destiny has said about me.
Mhm. You've heard him say that about me, right? No. No. No. >> It's
It's It's almost impossible to dig you out of it. >> Yeah, I
know. That's That's some [__] that Destiny has said
about me. Mhm. You've heard him say that. Mhm. About me?
>> He just realized he stepped in it. He goes, "Nope. Nope.
Nope. Actually, no. I've never heard that. Uh-huh.
Yaha.
Okay. >> that's It's not the case that if I'm truly convinced
one way or >> Dude, it's so crazy.
He He understands that he's like leaning into this exact narrative.
And as Pisco Pisco's like saying something. He goes, "Yeah. Yeah.
Okay. Yeah. Yeah, I've seen that. You've seen that, right? No.
>> the other on a given thing, I will like resist it or
I like I If If I really truly believe the other like something
else. There have been cases where I've been convinced. I was
proved wrong on my construal of Hitler being in favor of Christianity.
Um someone brought that up to me that that wasn't correct. And
I admitted it to them on stream that wasn't correct. I mean,
You're saying like these aren't examples. You're like like you're
skeptical >> arguing over historical facts is a little
different, especially like based on the conversation >> of
[__] I like. So So let me Well, let me demonstrate
to you that
Here Dude, here's the thing. Arguing over historical facts is
different. But why do you believe that Pisco is in the wrong?
That's the whole thing. You've come on here. You cannot defend
why you think something. You understand that, right? You've come
out to this stream. You've decided to hop on. And you had a really
strong opinion on Twitter.
And now you're trying to gaslight this guy into saying like he's
been wrong about all these things or or he's like "Fucked all
these different ways. He's [__] up by by his co-
because his co-host think he's like siding with somebody disingenuously.
Not even that they'll say that. Right? You're you're just trying
to make this argument that you're sort of putting together with
with glue and popsicle sticks. And you're not doing anything.
You're not doing anything substantial. You can't even argue it.
So, while arguing historical facts usually boils down to being
able to prove or not prove
in this case, you're not even making an argument. Like he understands
that it's different from historical facts. He understands it's
different from like a mathematical proof, but you're not even
attempting to take step one towards proving something. What would
I have to show you to convince you otherwise? >> Probably
a pattern of behavior. >> What a pattern of behavior of
what?
this most recent conversation you had with Hutch broke my brain
because I even think I said it in like the the one or two tweets
we had back at each other today was I can't believe that you
actually think that centrist meant a center Democrat. >> I
You don't then you didn't understand what I was saying. >> He
says not even arguing that. It could be a centrist Democrat.
It could be somebody further to the right. But there's it's both
are plausible. Both are used the same way. So, without contextual
information, you would have to go to the context and then you'd
have to make an argument that it's not just knowable. It is not
in a vacuum. It is always this way.
That in different contexts, you can make different arguments.
And so, you need the context. You need to actually make an argument
for why it means something in a specific case. >> Imagine
that I'm in the middle of of a walk and um there's an equidistant
riverbank and bank next to me and they say, "Go go to the go
to the bank." And I'm like, "Hang on a second.
What do you mean?" Right? Like the correct answer to the question
of where to go turns on what they mean by the command or the
question or the statement. Do you understand that?
>> So, so being accurate in saying point to the centrist
turns on what they mean when they are giving that test or demand
or question. >> Exactly. What I'm trying to show to you
is what the average person means. >> They mean >> Yo,
Saify. Thanks for the primer. >> Different things in different
contexts,
when people are talking about a centrist in normal everyday life,
what they are talking about is somebody who is one foot in the
Democrat side and one foot in the Republican side. >> Prove
it. Prove it. Prove it. Prove it. Prove it. Prove it. Prove it.
Prove it. Prove it. Prove it. Prove it. Prove it. Prove it. >> That's
literally the whole point. >> Does this guy not understand?
Like, he actually hasn't made an argument. Everybody agrees with
me on this. Everybody agrees with me here. You're weirdo pisco
and centrist means this. Okay. Show. Show examples. Examples
are where? Examples are where? Not just examples, but make an
argument. Make any argument.
Also, another dooby super chat.
Why the [__] would most would most normal everyday
people
think of centrist or moderate as pejorative, lmao? This might
be a true go touch grass moment.
I also think that's very critical to the article. Thank you so
much Diologist for the five gifted subs as well. Let's go. Let's
go.
We got another hour on the stream. Thank you very much. We are,
I think, what, a sub and a primer away from another hour on the
stream as well, but we're 2:36:11.
We got lots of time. We got lots of time. We're going to get
to everything today, okay? >> Prove it. Prove it. Prove
it. Prove it. Prove it. Prove it. That's your claim. So, you
just claimed that the majority default presumption in the American
conversation is that centrist means sometimes Republican, sometimes
Democrat in the way that you're suggesting. >> Look, but
you literally cradle it. Yes. >> Because we live in a two-party
system in the United States. We have a left and a right in this
country, right? >> Prove it. >> So, somebody can
be Prove it. Just prove that there's a left and a right. >> No, no,
no. Prove your claim. You You Prove it. Prove it. Prove it. Prove
it. >> You keep You keep just repeating Prove it. Like
you're making a point. >> So, you have a claim. >> My
claim is that in this country, we have a two-party system, correct?
>> I agree that we have a two-party system, but that's
not You're asking me >> So, we have a left and a right.
>> Say say, we have a two-party system. We have a left
and a right. Okay. >> Correct. You're asking me questions.
Prove it.
>> So, if somebody was straddling between
>> Now, Pisco Pisco is pretty pissed at this guy, so he's
saying use your own thought process, right? That's This is good.
Now, if Pisco could just apply this to Hutch, I would be in Nirvana,
okay? I would. What Pisco's trying to say is, "Stop asking me
questions and show that you have some internal monologue and
you're not just an NPC. Show me that you are capable of individual
independent thought. Do not ask me, oh, don't don't we have like
two
Assert it. Say, "I am asserting that we have two parties. I am
asserting that they are left and right generally in the in the
discourse. I am asserting" and then if he asks you to prove that,
you could go Oh, oh, I know what he's doing.
>> Oh, I just realized what he's doing. He's going to force
this guy to go to Wikipedia or a dictionary to look up a definition.
Oh, that's where it's going. I see. Prove it. How would you prove
it? Well, you'd have to go, well, what do these words even mean
in the first place? And then you have to pull out a dictionary
and this guy is basically getting mad and a bunch of people are
getting mad at Pisco for even bringing up a dictionary in the
terms of this
So, he's saying, "Prove it." How do you prove it? Well, you got
to go to a dictionary and see what the words mean or you got
to go to Wikipedia and see like broadly what somebody would mean.
You can't just say it. How do you prove something? How do you
prove that you breathe oxygen?
Right? If somebody comes out and says, "I don't believe we breathe
oxygen." How do you prove that? Well, it would actually be pretty
involved to go and prove that, right? From base level. You'd
have to know that process very
And that's the problem is Pisco is very very consistently arguing
in a way where he could prove that you breathe oxygen, right?
He could go through like
chemistry, biology, molecular science and he's like going to
prove this out, right? And so, that's what he's that's what he's
trying to do. He's trying to just say like, "Prove it. Just go
explain." Because when Pisco tries to prove it, people go, "Why
are you trying to prove it?" >> being left-wing and right-wing,
like let's say they had some right-wing views on crime and some
left-wing views on social issues, what would you call that >> You're
asking me questions. I'm asking you to prove your claim.
>> So, what would you accept as evidence? >> Uh so,
>> Would you want me to reach out to YouGov right now,
call them and see if they >> That would be a way. That
would be a way. If you're making If you're making a claim for
how people use words and what the what the predominant usage
is, that's an empirical claim, isn't it?
>> Is it an empirical claim?
>> See, do you see how he's slowly I didn't watch this
part. Do you see how he's slowly walking into, "Oh, I have to
use a dictionary
cuz they have a mechanism for deciding what words mean." And
it's like a whole administration, it's a whole organization,
it's an institution, really. And it's like the people who maintain
dictionaries are the people who tell you what words mean. That's
what he's He's slowly trying to walk him to like, "You would
have to use the
the dictionary, obviously." >> Yeah? No. Cuz language is
a little Explain how it would be empirical. >> So, the
reason why it's empirical is it's based on it's a data set. It's
based on looking at the facts of the matter. >> Okay, so
that's why I asked, what data set would you accept? >> Yeah,
so I would accept, for example, dictionary definitions. I would
accept polling and asking the question. I would >> So, you
are you literally I I I brought up a point to you that I thought
was a pretty fair point. How normal people in usually everyday
life, you know, this is
>> Oh, this guy This guy's like too low IQ to understand
what's going on here.
He's just too low IQ. He's just too You You understand you're
just trying to dumb this down because you lost. Like, that's
all it is. They're just trying to dumb it down repeatedly because
they >> how I believe that they use the word centralized
cuz it's how I've always understood it to be. That's how majority
people, in my opinion, understood it to be. And your response
to that was, "Get me a poll right now." >> Wait Wait, no,
no. I didn't just say >> That was Yeah, you said get >> Like,
Pisco has to basically take this guy through like philosophy.
Do you understand what liberalism is? Liberalism is a way of
maintaining some set of rights and maximizing personal liberty
such that it doesn't impede on other people's freedoms. That
requires discourse, discussion to see where your your principles
meet other people's principles and you're trying to balance them
in a way that you can function together in some society. How
do you do that? Well, you have discussions. Well, what happens
when disagreements arise? Well, then we have to have an argument.
Well, when you have an argument, how do you prove your side of
the argument? Well, you have to you have to use facts about the
world. How do you prove those facts? Well, I could basically
go and essentially do it from base level or I could find some
institution that does these things, that maintains these these
repositories of knowledge. I could reference them if we both
agree that that is reasonable, right? And obviously with definitions
of words, we have an institution that maintains what those definitions
are broadly and updates over time and tries to stay current.
And so obviously that is the answer for words. But he this guy
doesn't even understand that like, hey, the thing you say you
believe in, liberalism, requires discussion, disagreement, argument.
How do we engage in that?
>> Wait, show me the definition of the word right now.
Give it to me. So you made So first of all, you made a claim.
The fact that your claim might be hard to prove doesn't mean
that you don't have the burden to prove it. Agreed? And and I
didn't just say, "Go find me a poll right now." I said, "Go find
me a >> No, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, so you cuz you
so you made a claim, right? >> And I asked what >> Yeah,
and I then I answered you, didn't >> Mhm. And you said
a a dictionary definition or a poll. What else what did you point
to? Usage >> know. Because nobody no human being has conversations
like this, Pasco. That's what I think I try to tell you. >> Keep
us out of the meta, right? LIKE WHY DO YOU KEEP doing this?
nobody has conversations this way. They do when they disagree.
You're trying to You are trying to frame out possible
Antithetical to liberalism to just say your point your point
is stupid, we'll never entertain it. We're not even going to
discuss it. We can't have an argument about this. Your point
is stupid. My
>> You live in the meta. Do you swim in it? >> This
is not meta. >> You you bathe in the meta every day, man.
Whenever you Whenever these 4-hour conversations come up between
you and somebody on your show, for 3 and 1/2 hours, it's it's
quibbling over the the right usage and definition and shade and
color of a word. And every single time Every single time outside
of that, everyone walks away more confused than when they went
in. >> That's exactly That's exactly what I'm not doing,
right? My whole thing in the conversation is not to quibble on
the quote-unquote objective meaning, the objectively predominant
usage of the term centrist. What I was trying to do was exactly
the opposite. What I was trying to do is like, "Forget about
this. This is like a waste of time. Let's just ask what she means
by the word, and then go off of that assumption." It's directly
the opposite. I'm trying not to get dragged into like a conversation
about what is the correct terminology, what's the predominant
usage. I'm happy to accept any plausible usage. And I gave you
not an impossible >> I gave you a plausible usage, and
you were incredulous. >> I No, no, no, no. No. No. I agree
with No. I You're not listening. You're not You need to listen,
right? >> saying Just because you keep saying it doesn't
make it true, all right? And that's not a good tactic just to
make yourself seem right. >> I'm going to repeat it for
you. You're not listening. I'm going to repeat it for you. I
agree that your construal of centrist to mean sometimes that
he votes Democrat, sometimes he votes Republican, that's a plausible
usage of the word. It's one which is used, okay? It's used regularly.
It's used by me, okay? I agree with that. So, at no point was
I incredulous at the notion that that would be a usage of the
term. In fact, that's one of the offerings of the definitions
that I have provided. That's something that I accept and I use.
I use regularly to refer to enlightened centrists, these stupid
centrists, right? Like the people who are some Even sometimes
voters, right? Even though I probably shouldn't do that. Like
that is I'm not incredulous to that, okay? That's one of several
plausible ways that you can interpret centrist. Do you understand?
>> Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Okay. I I do appreciate Duby
just dropped all pretense. He's not even going to make actual
arguments that this guy could understand anymore. I'll give you,
sir, $10 if you can come up with a line of attack that isn't
verbatim from Destiny in the next half hour. >> And that
>> No, I completely understand that. >> Okay, it
just didn't seem like you understood that. Love Duby. Love this
>> I didn't What? I I didn't understand What do you think
I didn't understand >> Uh it seemed that you had trouble
with Hutch's definition, or >> Oh my god. >> It Listen,
there's a reason you had a 4-hour conversation with Hutch a day
or two ago, and you both left more confused than you went into
it. I have nothing to do with me. It has nothing to do with >> You
think I'm confused? >> I think Hutch is very unsatisfied.
>> Okay, I'm not confused by the conversation. I understand
exactly what
You think I'm confused? If P goes down, confused. Nobody Nobody
watches that in good faith is confused. It's very >> I
should have said unsatisfied instead of confused. I apologize.
>> The reason why I think that this is tricky is because
there is a conclusion that people want to draw, which I share,
which is that um this term centrist was used as a pejorative.
Let's just put everything else for now to pause right there,
and just dwell on that for a second. I agree with you. It was
framed. It was good guys and bad guys. I agree with the conclusion.
So, can we get the posturing off the table? That's my conclusion
as well. The only thing I'm critiquing is the reasoning in how
we get there. I'm trying to strengthen the argument against the
claim that it's not being done performatively or in a um in a
pejorative sense, okay?
That's meta. I'm trying I'm trying to I'm [laughter] not trying
to listen. I >> How do you think he did? Why do you think
everybody disagrees
That's a derail. That's a derail. Why are you Why are you derailing?
Why are you derailing?
>> If that is what you're trying to do, that's a great
thing. >> Because I think we should have this conversation.
It's obviously what I was trying to do.
>> It was I >> So, let me explain it.
Let me explain it then. So, let me let me explain it then. So,
the the reason why this question of whether Olivia Juliana is
actually a centrist is problematic for the claim that she is
using it as a pejorative or in some negative framing sense. The
reason why it's bad for that argument, in other words, trying
to settle on the truth of the matter here is bad, is because
there are plausible senses in which Taylor is correct that she's
a centrist, okay? There are plausible ways that the word is used,
regardless of how she self-IDs, regardless of what you >> Regardless
of how she uses the word. >> Correct. Regardless of how
she uses the word, uh that is to say, Olivia Juliana, >> thinks
it's Taylor. By the way, when the first time Taylor's asked about
this, she says, "Oh, I think she's a centrist Democrat."
Olivia Juli- because she self-ID'd that way, and it's not important.
Like, I'd be happy to change it if she felt like it was a mischaracterizing
her views, right? And so, from that from that first example,
where Taylor like unpacks what she means there, it's like the
conversation should die right there, and it should move forward.
Just to be clear, right? Assuming you think moderate and centrist
are synonyms, the conversation should die there. At least on
on whether or not this person self-ID'd, whether or not you could
plausibly use it. Now, it's Now, if you want to have the dog
whistle discussion, you can go ahead and go further, but you're
going to look silly to everybody. >> Well, well, no, no,
yeah, >> to everybody who knows what a dog whistle is.
You're the guy who's going, "No, no, no, when you did this okay
simple thing, you actually you actually hate black people. You're
actually a white nationalist cuz you did this okay hand, okay?"
That's it. That's it. We're not even going to talk about it.
We can't even talk about it. >> regardless of her intent,
the factual accuracy, um there are some ways, uh you know, independent
of people's subjective beliefs, that she is plausibly a centrist,
okay? And me seeing that, I'm like, "If if if Hutch fights on
the truth or falsity of whether Olivia Juliana is a centrist,
it's a losing argument." The reason it's a losing argument is
because people come to different conclusions on what constitutes
a centrist, and it's a a kind of amorphous word that is really
dependent on the context. That's why it's silly to die on that
hill. Isn't that the most obvious thing in the world? What you
got to do is get what Taylor means. What Taylor means by it,
get that on the table, and then cruise off fire with it. It's
make it ex- >> And that's why, wait, I'm sorry, but I I
feel like Hutch, whether she was >> did bring up this >> So,
so, >> So, what they did eventually bring up the like different
ways in which she would mean centrist. Um Taylor did provide
some sense of what she meant. She said a middle-of-the-road Democrat.
She did say those words. You can say she didn't mean it. That
is a plausible sense of what centrist means. It doesn't quite
pin her to the ground. Then later on, she said like aligned with
Democrats uh loosely. That is a more a way that you can make
more hay out of it. She referenced self-ID as a potential concept,
but it wasn't a clear cashing out of what she meant, right? There
wasn't clarity on what she meant there and she was able to be
tricky and evasive and be better, okay? You'd be more effective.
No, no, no, okay, whether I did or not is beside the Whether
I did or not is is beside >> Um, Hutch helped with it.
Pisco, you literally could have asked Pisco what he meant. Hutch
helped with it by spurking the [__] out instead of
just asking Pisco what he meant. That's who helped. Hutch's bad
reaction to to advice, like good faith, good advice from his
friend is what caused that.